Why your business isn't growing. And so,
we have our inputs, we have
efficiencies, and we have an output.
And so, this output, most of the time
for a business, is money, right?
The issue that I continue to see is that
people aren't clear on what the inputs
are.
And so, taking to this extreme, I could
say, "Okay, if no one knows that your
gym exists,
will you make money?"
No.
So, we have to get people to know that
you exist. All right, step one, people
have to know you exist. And so, right
now,
part of some of your problems is that
not enough people know that you exist.
And so, what do we do to increase how
many people know that we exist?
We get traffic, or we advertise.
Now,
if advertising is the thing that we're
going to do to get more people to know
about our stuff,
what is the primary method of
advertising that you have right now?
Now, for those guys who Who here read
Leads, by the way, the book? Oh, neat.
Thank you, appreciate it. Um so, you can
reach out to people
that you know or don't know.
You can make content. You can run ads.
Or, realistically, you can get an
affiliate partner who does those things
for you. But, for everyone here, so we
can make this interactive, who here only
uses ads to get customers, or primarily
uses ads to get customers?
Okay, so it looks like about a quarter,
quarter to a third. Okay. Who here uses
outreach to get customers primarily?
Oh, less. Okay, like 10%. Okay. Who uses
making content to get customers?
Interesting. That was higher than I
expected.
Who here has referral partners who refer
you business on a regular basis, and
that's the primary way you get
customers? Okay, not a ton. Okay. So,
the reason this is so important is that
if your business is struggling, or
you're you're struggling to grow your
business,
then it means that if the first step in
the chain for you making money is that
people find out about the stuff,
a lot of you guys aren't letting people
know, and you haven't boiled it down to
the inputs. So, I'm going to come back
to this page.
If we have content as your primary way
of getting customers, if we have paid
ads,
if we have outreach,
and if we have referrals or referral
partners,
then we have to boil this down to the
activities that we need to do in order
to do more of it, right? So, you're
like, "Okay, I make content." So, then
the question is how much are you making
and how good is it? Now, I personally
believe that for local businesses, the
purpose of content is not to get
customers, it is to convert a higher
percentage of customers. Because most of
the algorithms on these platforms are
global. And so, if you make content and
you're in Idaho, and the vast majority
of people who see your content are not
in Idaho, or not even in a 5-mi radius,
who cares?
Unless you want to go in the online
thing, which is a totally different
game. And so, I see the purpose of
making content as a local business owner
as something that when you do reach out,
or if someone does get referred to you,
or you do run an ad, people click over
to your page and they see if you're
legit, or if you look friendly, you look
nice, they look at the equipment, they
look at the facility, they say, "Oh,
this place looks cool. Oh, it's right by
where I live, or it's right on my way to
work." And then they make a decision to
move forward.
So, if you're currently making zero
content, super light lift, make some,
like one a week, so you just look like
you have a heartbeat online.
Really high ROI for like one piece a
week.
Beyond going above that, then you get
into the I want to make content as my
primary marketing mechanism, and now
you're driving volume and quality
through that.
So,
this then, if content is your primary
way, which I'm still amazed by for of
you who that's what you do, is that you
want to start thinking, how do I make
And for context, we make about 400
pieces of content a week
posted.
It's a lot.
And so, you're like, wait a second.
You're like doing the math. You're like,
that's 55 pieces a day. It's a lot. It's
more than two an hour. So, a lot.
And so,
as a baseline, let's start with like two
a day.
Something that you can do. And the
reason I want to boil this down this way
is that if you're like, I can't grow my
gym, I can't grow my business,
and the thing that grows my business is
that I make content,
then do a shitload more of that.
I know.
Crazy.
It's what I'm known for, the very deep
insights. All right.
So, so paid ads,
which was, I think, the largest
percentage of you here, still
a minority, which
half frightens me for you, but we'll
keep going.
Paid ads.
The thing that you do when you run paid
ads is that you're spending money every
day. So, the actual platform does the
distribution of the content for you,
does the distribution of the offer for
you, so that you can generate leads. But
the work of making paid ads that you do
every day is in the creative. It's in
scripting out the ads, thinking through
the hooks, doing research on other ads
that are working in the weight loss
space, and thinking, okay, how can I
emulate that? Part of that might be I
have to learn how to use one of those
phone editing softwares.
Yeah, that's that's the job. That's
work. That's how it works.
And so,
for each of these activities, I'll give
you my rule of thumb, which is that it's
4 hours a day.
And some of you are going to be like,
gulp, 4 hours a day?
Yeah.
Trying to grow, right?
Like I I don't We'll get to this in the
second half of this this talk, but
if this is the input into the system
that makes everything go burr,
then this is the thing that makes you
money.
And everything that you're doing that's
not this is not making you as much money
as doing more of this.
And for most small businesses, if you're
under $100,000 a month,
you just need to let people know that
you exist. And some of you guys are
concerned about your brands and things
like that. The brand is 100% going to be
delivered based on the quality of the
product quality quality of the services
that you give. So, I'm going to give you
a quick little little hack here and then
we'll come back to this.
So, brand
can only be built in three ways.
One is what you say.
The second is what other people say.
And the third is what people experience
themselves.
And so, what ends up happening is in the
beginning you have no customers. In the
beginning it was dark, right? So,
you say stuff. You say, "Hey, my stuff's
awesome. Look, it's clean, it's stuff
it's
it's in the neighborhood that you like,
it's safe, whatever. You won't get hurt
here. You'll look nice and skinny. You
want to be skinny? Look at me, I'm
skinny, too. You could be like me." So,
you say these things. Great.
Then somebody will buy.
And then if they have good things to
say, they leave you reviews. And then
the person who's considering buying is
like, "Okay, well, I like what they were
saying and other people seem to be
saying nice stuff. So, then maybe I will
buy."
But then as soon as they do buy, they
actually have an experience personally.
So, here, these two things are
approximations. These two things are
advertising.
This
is product.
Because somebody can come out with the
coolest, most premium, sweetest-looking
brand in the world, but if you buy the
shirt and it has holes in it, not the
holes that are cool, just holes,
it's going to suck and you'll be like
these guys are full of it.
If you go to if you wait in line forever
for this swanky new restaurant because
they say they were really cool and
expensive and other people say they were
really cool and expensive and then you
go there and you're like this is not
cool and just expensive.
You're like I hate this place.
And so immediately there's a promise
that you're making here and then you
deliver it here and if you deliver based
on the promise you make that reinforces
the brand and then these people become
these people.
And they say nice [__]
And that is how you build a brand in a
local business. That's it. It's all
about the delivery and the reality is
the vast majority, I'll say the average
person here is mediocre.
Just waiting for that to hit but maybe
it didn't. Anyways.
Half of you're below average. I know.
Um
But the real real is like everybody
here, most people would say no, our
gym's like the amount of times that I
heard
my gym's amazing if people just came in
to experience it. I'd be like do you
have customers? They're like yeah. And
I'm like and they're not getting you
more customers?
Not amazing.
You're not that good.
Come and that's okay. But the problem is
when you think you are good and then
don't put any attention to it because
you delude yourself into thinking that
you're so good that no one talks about
your [__]
I'm so good people just want to keep me
a secret.
Sure.
It's like I love you so much baby I just
can't bring you in public.
Okay.
So back to advertising. All right.
So you're making two pieces of content
today if that's what you're doing. If
you're doing running paid ads you want
to commit to a certain dollar amount per
day and I can't impress this upon you
enough is it like you spend this money
before you eat.
Like this is how your business eats.
This is not this is not feeding your
child
if you don't spend this money.
Because this is how you distribute your
message. It's how people find out about
your stuff. This is the input into the
system that goes burn and makes money.
So, you spend the money and then your 4
hours for this is about how to make ads.
And that's the skill. If you do that
every day, guess what? You'll get way
better at making ads.
And so I'll give you a little hack that
I do.
One,
whenever I see an ad of any kind So,
one, I'm not premium on anything. I want
to see the ads.
If I like an ad, I save it.
I screenshot it and I have an album
that's all the ads that I like.
Then, when I go to start making ads,
which if it's you, you're going to be
doing this every day, I go back, I
review my all-time greatest ads, and I
like to drink them in. So, I'm like,
okay, these are the words that I was
saying, these are the hooks, these are
the settings that I was using. Okay,
these are the pain points I brought up.
And then, I look at the new ads that
I've seen that week that I thought were
kind of interesting and I say, okay,
what elements from this can I merge with
the stuff that I already know to create
something that's kind of new?
And so then, I make a whole bunch of
those
and I take my winning ads and I just
make them again.
Like, same words, same I just do it
again.
And then, I run them and I see how
they're doing and if I want to learn an
effect, I Google how to put this effect
on a video and then we put the effect on
the video and then the ad starts
performing or it doesn't and guess what
you do tomorrow, you do it a [__]
again.
And like,
I have had a lot of conversations with
gym owners
in my life.
And
I'm not going to get to the second part
of this talk cuz otherwise I'm going to
I'm going to
I'll get more offensive. So, I'm going
to wait. I'll I'll complete this thought
process.
So,
okay.
Please, please spend money on ads,
please, so that people can find out
about your gym.
And if your stuff sucks, then how are
you going to get better besides kind of
like
bringing people in so that you can learn
that you suck and then getting practice
so that you can get better.
Cuz you can spend all the time in the
world trying to imagine how good your
customer success, you know, is going to
be until you have like 20 new members
and you're like, "Oh my god,
everything's broken. I don't have any
process for anything and like I suck and
my trainer was late and wow, what a
terrible experience."
But you can't have that learning and
till they walk in the door.
So, you're running paid ads. If you're
doing outreach, which was like 10% of
you guys,
I'm going to say it again, but the rule
of 100
it just it just works. It's consistent
as gravity. It works. Problem is most
people don't work and so that's why they
don't make money.
They like to think about working
and they like to come up with excuses
for other things that became quote
urgent that never are.
In a gym,
there's basically no emergency.
I had I remember I got a call at like
4:30 in the morning when there was a
water main that broke pouring over my
floor.
And my trainer called me and he was
like, "Hey, we have an emergency."
He said that and I immediately assumed
someone's dead.
I was like, "Heart attack, someone's on
the floor and if that's the case, why
are you calling me? Call [__] 911."
But he was So, he said that and he was
like, "Are you ready?" And I was like,
"Yes, just tell me." And he was like,
"It's a water main." I was like, "Well,
what are you calling me for? I'm not a
plumber. I was like, "Call a plumber."
And I could have slept a couple hours. I
wasn't going to change anything.
What do you want me to do? What do you
think you should do? Work out outside.
Great idea. Do that.
WHY ARE YOU CALLING ME?
There's no emergencies. Like unless
you're in health care and you're in
shock trauma, there are no emergencies.
And so I say this to underline one
point, which is that many of you become
distracted by things that you perceive
to be emergencies, but the real
emergency is that you're doing the [__]
you need to do to grow your business.
Thanks.
With the music. There you go.
It's a real bar. Okay.
So, last one's referral. Um
and I'm going to say when I say referral
here, I mean a referral partner, meaning
you have a chiropractor, you have a
doctor that you helped out and they have
a huge practice and they start sending
you and you create some sort of
relationship. That you still do these
things to attract this person. And if
you're like, "Man, if I only I've got
this one guy and he sends me like half
my customers." Well, how amazing would
it be if you had 10 of those guys or 20
of those guys? Well, you know how you do
that? You ask them.
You reach out to them. You give them
gifts. You bribe them.
Really.
It's how it works.
And you know how you bribe another
business owner? You send them business.
If you want someone to send you
business, send them business first.
Little rule of life. It works a lot
better that way. Okay.
So, we have our inputs and our outputs
in the system, right? So, it starts with
advertising. And for the vast majority
of you guys,
you are not advertising enough.
That's it.
Who here spends 4 hours a day, 6 days a
week
advertising doing one of those four
things?
Does your gym make money?
Yeah.
It's like, "I don't have a gym, but yes,
I make money." It's like, "What are you
doing here?" IT'S CALLED JIM CON. All
right.
I promise you,
if you spend 4 hou- Like, 4 hours a day
is not much.
Like, 4 hours a day.
I don't know.
Like, what are you doing?
Why your business isn't growing.
You're not trying to grow it.
All right. Cool. Well,
I mean, we could just stop there.
None of you are even doing it. All
right.
Well, let's talk about efficiency while
we're at it. It doesn't matter cuz
you're not putting anything in the
system anyways, but let's talk about it.
So,
fundamentally,
I'm being dead serious.
It's It's It's like it doesn't
If I were to spend a full day with each
of you,
I'd be like, "Oh, okay. Well, what are
we going to do with the rest of our
eight, you know, seven hours and 40
minutes that we have for this day?" Cuz
that's the problem. But, okay, let's
talk about efficiency. So,
fundamentally, you got to let people
know. Fantastic. Now they know, you got
to get them to give you money, which is
going to be the conversion process. All
right? Cool. Conversion is going to be
the next step in this efficiency.
I'll give you I'll I'll give you a
little spoiler to the next ones. Then
you've got your price,
and then you've got your churn.
And I'm saying this specific to gyms cuz
it's recurring business. Okay.
So, if we think about what a business
is,
you get more customers or you make them
worth more. That is the only way that
you will make more money.
Fundamentally, that is it. There's no
other way. Get more customers, make them
worth more. If we double click into each
of these, getting more customers means
you need more traffic and better
conversion.
And so, if right now you're not getting
enough customers, it means you need more
traffic or better conversion.
If you need to make your customers worth
more, the only thing you can do to make
them worth more is you raise your
prices, you decrease churn.
That's what you have control over.
And so, if you're like, "Okay, how do I
make my customers worth more?" Raise
your prices,
get them to buy more times. That's what
churn Decreasing churn is getting them
to buy for 10 months rather than 5
months, or 3 months.
And so, the idea here is that once we
feed the machine, this is the raw input,
this is eyeballs, this is the activities
that you do that get people to find out,
then it's about how many of these things
can we turn into money?
And how much money can we turn it into?
And so, the most efficient gyms are ones
that
convert a very high percentage, at a
very high price, and get people to buy
lots of times.
And so,
this is from a Contrarian's perspective,
figure out what's wrong with your gym,
and for everybody who didn't raise their
hand, which is literally everyone here,
it's this.
But we'll talk about the other three.
Is that
you have steps within this conversion
process.
You have to get them to schedule, you
have to get them to show, and you've got
to close.
So, who here sucks at sales?
Any gay hand?
Some of you suck at sales, that's fine.
It's helpful to actually It's like the
first step is being like, "Hi, my name's
Sarah, and I can't close a door." Uh, so
it's okay.
And so,
if you want to get better at sales, if
that's the problem, you're getting leads
in the door, but you can't close,
then you practice closing, and you do
that for 4 hours a day.
And so, there's probably a meta takeaway
here, which is that whatever the big
problem in my business is, that's what
my first 4 hours
every day
are spent doing.
Until I solve that problem.
And then I change what that 4 hours is
spent on. But that 4 hours that I spend
in the morning, before everyone gets
there, or if you're a late-night person,
the last hours of the day, when
everyone's asleep, that is what moves
the business forward.
The vast majority of people skip those 4
hours and go straight to firefighting
all day, but the thing is is that if you
look back on last month, or 2 months, or
3 months back, the only thing that you
really will have to show for progress is
what you did in those 4 hours.
It's something that it took me a little
bit of time to realize. And I was like,
"Oh, if I don't do it in that 4 hours,
nothing big moves forward." But what I
can promise is that I don't remember any
of the fires that I put out last month.
The fires are going to happen and they
will get put out. You'll also find that
if you ignore them, they tend to also go
away.
Real talk.
And so
And so if you're having a conversion
issue from sales, you practice sales.
The way you practice sales is you
role-play. You do it with somebody else.
Play with a friend.
It's how it works.
And you want fast feedback loops. You
need to be able to breathe the script.
And
the secret to making sure that you don't
sound dumb in the sale is you make them
sound dumb in the sale. And you do that
by asking questions.
So no one can oppose you, this is a
little pro tip, no one can oppose you if
you make no statements.
So whoever answers questions in the sale
is the one who's losing.
And so you can even address this with
every single obstacle that you ever come
in contact with.
Well,
"What certifications do you guys have
here?"
Which one are you looking for?
They don't know.
This is a question their friend told
them to ask. They have no idea.
And then they're like, uh,
"You know, what are the workouts like?"
Well, what's your dream workout?
They tell you. You're like, "Well, it's
not that."
If I really want to be like, "Well,
how's that working for you?" "Well, I
don't do them." "Okay."
That's why you're here? Cool. Well, then
why don't you do our workouts?
So the thing is is you There's always a
way to sidestep objections by just
asking what they're trying to get out of
the question that they're asking you.
And most of the time they have no idea
because you should know the answer to
their question better than they do cuz
you've had this conversation before.
Imagine having the same conversation
over and over again and sucking at that
one conversation.
Mind blown. It's also like not
advertising your [__] business.
Anyways.
So you've got show rates.
You've got uh schedule rates.
And you've got close rates.
So, that's our conversion efficiency.
And so,
whichever one of these is below a
benchmark is the one that you spend your
hours on. I will also promise you that
schedule rate and show rate, if you
actually spend 4 hours a day on it, will
not be a problem
at all.
But, everyone just wants this to just go
away magically and wants everyone just
like show up ready to close. Like, my
leads suck.
All leads suck.
Until they become customers, then
they're amazing. Right? But, then like
the process of taking a lead and making
it into a customer is work.
And everyone's afraid of doing that. And
if you're looking to make your first
dollar online or monetize your audience,
no matter what the size is,
school.com/games
is the easiest way that I know how to do
it. I take a call once a week inside of
that community to answer questions for
people who are getting started. I have a
step-by-step course that lays out what
exactly to do to make your first dollar
online. And once a month, I drop 8 hours
of training from the top 10 community
business owners showing exactly what
they're doing to scale their communities
today. school.com/games,
you can start for free.
And so, now we get into LTV. So, you
advertise more, you work on these things
for conversion to increase the
conversion rate you have in the
business.
And then you've got price and churn.
Now,
Cale, I'm sure talked about pricing at
some point. Yes?
Okay.
You're probably priced too low.
And it's not because we want to destroy
your gym.
You're priced too low because at that
price you will not make a profit.
The amount of times that I had gym
owners were like, "My gym's full and I'm
not making money." And I was like, "Do
you see a problem?"
Like, you can't service any more
customers, but you don't make any money.
Get where I'm going with this?
Like, something has to change. And if
you're already full, we just need to
increase the price.
You're mispriced, and that's okay.
Like, that's how you learn.
But for many of you, you just need to
send an email and send a letter and let
people know that from this point going
forward, this is the new price.
Grab your your big boy and big girl
pants and say like, I'm going to take
this risk because the other way is
guaranteed to never work.
That's the thing is like, we want to
stay in the same boat and be like, you
know what?
Even though all the math makes sense
with this higher price, I'm afraid and
I'm going to let that stop me forever
from getting the business to be where it
needs to be.
That sucks.
So, don't think that.
Make the bet
and then deliver like that actually is
your price.
And do a really good job on the back
end.
And the way that you do a good job,
which
Jim launches already given you, but you
have exit interviews with people on the
way out the door. You can save half of
them by saying, "Oh, you're right. I
didn't give you enough support. You
should go into this higher thing. That's
what actually gives you the support."
You save half your customers. Awesome.
You reach out to them every 2 weeks or
so as though you actually cared about
them.
That was a joke. But um
No one laughed at that one. Anyways, so
So, you reach out to them every couple
weeks and you just make sure it's a
touch base. It's a pulse check. You
don't even need to talk about fitness.
It's just to make sure that they know
that you know that they exist.
You track attendance. When someone says
that they're actually going to show up
for a time, you make sure they show up.
And if they don't show up, you say,
"Hey, Marley, where were you? I missed
you."
We actually track this and we could
watch people go from three times a week,
three times a week, two times a week,
one time a week, cancel. You can just
watch it if you track attendance.
But if you implement that, you go three
times a week, three times a week, two
times a week, Marley, get your ass in
here, three times a week, three times a
week and she keeps going.
They have to know that they're missed.
The next one, and this is something that
happened later in my life that I
learned, is about onboarding. So, when
somebody comes in the door and you do
sell them, the next 24 hours are
absolutely crucial to making is setting
all the expectations of what their
experience is going to be.
And so, right now, if your onboarding
process is show up on Monday,
tough.
Very hard.
And so, if there's ever a time where you
invest more resources into a customer,
it's in that first 24, 48, 72 hours so
that they know exactly where they're
going to go at what time, who's going to
talk to them, who reconfirms they're
showing up because they're petrified
because they've worked out in 6 years
and they feel terrible and they used to
be a high school weight and they can't
look at the scale now cuz it makes them
feel terrible. Whatever. Right? And we
have to deal with this
by over communicating in the window of
time that makes the most sense. And so,
even if it feels like it takes a little
bit more effort, I promise you, you will
get two, three, five more purchases from
this person in terms of months by just
making sure that they know when they're
supposed to be there, who's going to be
there to welcome them, and who's going
to show them around a little bit in the
beginning so that they don't feel like
they're completely lost.
Okay.
That's churn.
Fantastic.
So,
right now, if your business is not
growing as much as you want, you're not
advertising enough. If you're
advertising enough and people are
finding out about it, you're getting
leads, they're either not scheduling,
not showing, or not closing. If it's one
of those three, then all of your effort
in that first 4 hours of the day is to
get him in the schedule, get him in the
show, get him to close.
If you're getting all of that stuff,
you've got lots of people and you're
closing them all,
but you're not making any money, you're
mispriced.
And if you're getting all of this and
you have a high price, but everyone
falls out the back door, you have to
make your stuff better.
And this is how you walk through it.
This is how you figure out what the
problem in the business is. And so, who
here has capacity
in their gym right now?
Okay.
Start there.
So,
that is part one of my talk.
Everyone feel good about that?
Okay.
Thank you.
So, part two of the talk is reverse
engineering your goal.
And so, the reason that I broke down the
activities that you need to do into
those four things is because we have to
figure out how many customer or how many
activities
equals one customer.
So, if you know that on average you
post,
let's say, 30 times a month. So, you
post 30 times a month. And from those 30
posts that you make,
you get five customers.
Which for most of you is not the case
because you're local businesses and this
doesn't work that way. But, since that's
what 20% of you are doing, we'll talk as
though that's what happens.
So, if you make 30 posts and you get
five customers, you could say for every
six posts I get one customer. Okay. So,
I need to make more posts and I need
better posts. And if you're like, "Okay,
I want to get to
25 customers is my goal."
It's just a goal.
Then, I need to 25x this.
So, then we get 150, which means I need
to do five a day.
Okay.
This is something I can control.
Is this making sense? This is literally
what I do with the businesses that we
buy. I just say, I just boil everything
down to like, "What do we do that makes
us money?" Not all the stuff after that.
What do we do that makes us money? And
they're like, "Okay, we have an outbound
team." I'm like, "Okay, so what are the
outbound activities?" It's like, "Well,
we haven't tracked it well yet." Well,
start.
So, let's say you do 100 reach outs.
And that creates one customer.
Okay.
And currently you're getting 10
customers.
Currently.
Fantastic. And so that means you're
doing 1,000 per month.
Which means you're doing 30 per day.
Okay. Well, if I want to get to 50
customers a month, then I need to 5x
this to get to 150 per day.
And then that gets me my 50 customers.
And what's interesting is that
when you do actually increase the volume
that much, you also get better.
So, you actually get leverage on the
time because your skill improves.
If you do 100 shots a day for a while,
you get pretty good at it.
But when you start in the beginning and
you do 10 a day,
you just tend to keep sucking.
Because you never do enough to turn the
corner to get enough reps in. So, let me
ask you a different question maybe drive
this home. Has anyone had a day where
you had like or like maybe a week where
you had a lot of sales, you had two,
three, four appointments a day for like
a week straight? Can I get a hand? Okay.
Did you feel like you were way hotter?
Like when you were selling, you're like,
"Okay." Cuz you get these fast feedback
loops. You're like, "All right, I got
another one in and another one in an
hour." And then you like practice again.
Ooh. And so like you're sharpening the
sword.
On the flip side, you have a dead week
and you have like two sales consults,
it's like you got to like you like like
brush the rust off, right? Like the
amount that you work, the amount of
volume you do, will directly feed into
how good you are at it. And that's why
the rich keep getting richer is that
they do more and by doing more, they get
more from their more. They get better,
too.
And so that's how skills start
compounding and that's how you can just
blow everyone away. Like the idea that
any single person here gives a [__] what
the guy down the street is doing,
baffles me.
It just doesn't matter
at all.
Because that guy
is like everyone else here and not even
advertising.
And he's mispriced and he's breaking
even even though his classes are there
people running outside looking crazy. He
still doesn't take any money home. You
know I know cuz I've looked at so many
gym owner P&Ls. No one makes money
except for the guys who track their
stuff, know their imports, actually
advertise, work their leads, price
appropriately, and remind customers to
actually use the gym.
It's just that the bar for winning is
not that high.
And so I I was going to wait to make
this like the last part of the
presentation, but I'm going to end up
going here, so whatever.
I
I don't
I don't understand
why you don't do this.
Because like
everything you want is on the other side
of you getting the business that works,
that generates a profit, that keeps your
customers happy, that provides for your
team. Like everything that you want is
on the other side of that.
And you're like you're like on Facebook.
And I I I just I don't I don't get it.
Like it I just I don't get it. It's
beyond me.
And so
And this is the part that I said was
similar between
companies of this size. So I'm going to
give you hopefully the highest ROI hack
that you will only be able to do at this
level. Under 150,000 a month. You'll
never be able to get this again.
It will only happen at this stage.
And so when I think about conferences
and workshops and things that I've
attended,
you all have a lot of notes. You've a
lot of stuff written down that you're
like, I need to do all seven pages of
these notes.
But, we'll be real. You'll fly back.
You'll put the notes somewhere, or that
Google Doc will start moving down in the
recency thing, and then you'll be like,
oh wait, what was it I what was I going
to do?
And so,
realistically, you have like a sticky
note that has like three things on it
that you're actually going to do.
Everything else, really great ideas,
might not be what you need right now.
Because every business only has one
constraint.
And until you can de-constrain it, it
will stay stuck.
And then when you do that, it will grow
until it's next constraint. And that's
how business works.
And so, I want to make sure that the
three things on that sticky note are the
right three things that will make you
the most money.
So,
what if I told you that there were a way
that you could get So, who right now,
imagine your best employee. Who here has
employees? Just to make sure I've got
Okay, thank god. Okay. So,
imagine the best employee you have.
If you could have
twice that, would you make more money?
Would you be willing to pay
$1,500 a month?
This isn't going where you think it is.
$1,500 a month to get that employee, a
double, a clone, if you will, of that
employee. Would you do it?
Yes.
All right.
So,
the average American
spends
20 I think it's 20 I'm at My numbers are
going to be close. 24 hours
per month
on food.
Food.
As in going to the grocery store,
prepping, cooking, cleaning up after
yourself, consuming the food, and
cleaning up after the dishes that you
made.
All of that, 24 hours a month.
The average American also, so this is
food, for cleaning, cleaning their
homes,
spends
I
You know what?
It might be per week. I can't remember.
I'll just say the three level and I
don't remember the stats. But, for
cleaning, it's like 20 hours
per month that people spend.
And then laundry
is like 19 or something.
All of these on a monthly basis
add up to 96 hours, which is what I
actually remember.
Between all the time you spend on food,
all the time you spend cleaning,
all the time you spend doing laundry,
all the time you spend doing human
stuff,
like things for your human, this body
bag you got to walk around in. Right?
Really annoying.
No one can do
Like, no one go to the I mean, if I
could I If I could delegate like going
to the bathroom and showering, like dear
god, it'd be awesome.
There's a point to this.
You can get 96 hours a month back
by paying 1,500 bucks a month to get
someone to make all your food for you,
clean your house,
and do your laundry.
And hold on, hold on.
And you would do this for the most
valuable person in your business
who's not your employee, it's you.
You're happy to do it for them, but you
don't do it for you because you don't
want to waste money.
But you would literally do it for a
teammate who's not as good as you, and
I'm making a bet here cuz they don't
know in the business and they're
probably not as skilled as you are cuz
you probably taught them half the stuff
they know.
And you're not doing it.
And so I want to break this like if I
can if I can get every single person
here 96 hours a month,
it's almost it's more than two full work
weeks.
And the difference is like I I don't get
into like stop watching Netflix and
television and all that stuff cuz that's
another 100 hours. But you guys like
that stuff and you're not going to stop,
so who cares? I'm not even going to get
into that.
You are. Whatever.
But no one likes this.
Now, if you like cooking, fine. That's
leisure. But like
prepping your food, prepping other
people's food, going grocery shopping.
No one's like, "Man, I just love grocery
shopping." Well, some of you do. You're
[__] weird. But
But
But it's not worth it.
And so right now,
remember I'm laddering up to this.
The 4 hours a day that no one here is
spending to actually grow their company,
I just found it.
And for $1,500 a month, and I said you
can only do this once. I can only
outsource my food one time in my career.
After that, I don't get to gain again.
You're at a point where you have to
start valuing your time and being
willing to trade dollars for time. Like
if you had to hire somebody for two
grand a month, you're like, "Oh, wow.
What a steal."
But I'm asking you to hire yourself for
another 96 hours a month by getting rid
of all this stuff on your plate that's
not making you money.
And so when I go when I go back to this
idea of
the stuff that grows your business is
really straightforward.
And so I was racking my brain. I was
like, "Why don't people do this?"
And maybe you're tired. Maybe you're
distracted.
Well,
when I had these meetings where I talked
to these smaller, you know, with the
business owners that are between 10 and
150,000 a month,
this is what they're telling me they're
spending their time on.
And it
Don't. Stop.
And I promise you if you spend 96 hours
a month on the constraint of your
business, it will grow.
A lot.
And then every you'll be a year and
everyone's like, "What did What was your
secret?" Like, "Alex told me I should
stop cooking my own food and then I
started working my leads." Like,
"And we made more money."
If you can make more than $15 an hour
actively working, cuz that's what 1,500
bucks divided by 96 is roughly,
then it's worth it.
Now, if you do that and then you do
nothing with the extra 96 hours, then
shame on you. You deserve to be poor.
So,
please do that.
It's on the sticky on the on the sticky
note for the day.
Is that maybe sticky point number one?
Spend 4 hours a day on the constraint of
my business. Sticky note number two,
make sure that I actually
get those 4 hours a day in by paying for
all the things that are not that.
And so once you're really clear on the
things that you actually have to do from
an activity perspective,
the rest becomes elimination.
And so right now, a lot of you guys have
a lot of things on your to-do list,
right? I'm sure. Especially leaving
here. Like, "Oh my god, I have all this
stuff I have to do."
But, I would encourage you to focus on
your to-don't list. Like, really really.
I
I get a lot of I get a lot of credit for
the speed that we moved in business. And
I would I would put a disproportionate
amount of effort or weight on the fact
that I we just try not to spend time
doing stuff that doesn't matter.
And trying to not spend time
wasting mental energy on things that I
can buy to replace.
And so like, when I was a single guy, I
get made fun of on TikTok now for it,
but like I just went to Chipotle for all
my meals. I never bought groceries cuz
it didn't make any sense.
Cuz I was like, "Well, if I close a
sale, that's $500.
And that's all my Chipotle for like 2
weeks.
And then I can not worry about food at
all. And then the next hour I can close
another $500 and be like, "Well, that's
that's my cleaning for the month."
And then the next hour, right? See what
I'm saying here?
But, if if you if you think small, you
stay small. Like you got to be willing
to take the bet. And if there's ever
been somebody to reinvest your time into
getting more skills,
why on earth would you not do it for
you?
Okay. So, I'm going to do two more.
Okay, I'm good. So, I got I'm going to
do two more two more quick
topics.
So,
one of the things that I prided myself
on was
buying education, buying experiences,
buying help to move faster.
And
anyone here have a client that you're
like, "They're just an amazing client. I
could have just said like run that way
and just eat less and they would have
just succeeded." And you're like hands
if you've had that client. I love that
client. They leave the best
testimonials. They're the great before
and after pictures.
On the other hand, who here's had Susan?
You already know Susan. We We all know
Susan.
Right? Susan has a slow metabolism. All
right, and she has very bad genetics.
And uh big-boned is you know everyone in
her family is. And uh you know, she's
been to a couple doctors. They gave her
some medications and nothing's worked.
And
you know when you start, she's already
blamed nine people for the fact that she
cannot control
this.
Being real, how do you think you get
fat?
This.
Just this. This one activity. That's it.
And she's blamed every other person on
earth for the fact that she can't stop
doing it.
Some of you guys are Susan with your
business.
You're not this person who can go watch
a YouTube video and immediately execute
everything and be an amazing client.
You're Susan. You're saying my market
sucks. My leads are bad.
Like this the price change didn't work
for me.
My churn's high because people don't
value my product. Duh.
And so it's just this loser victim
wanting to buy things only to prove that
it won't work for you so that you can be
self-affirmed in the fact
that it's not your fault.
It's ridiculous. It's Susan. You're
Susan.
Susan sucks.
And the thing is is that they're like I
if like even one of you is like, "You
know what? I do kind of do that."
My goal of every time I get into
anything that's education-based has
always been to not be a success story,
but to be the number one person they
have ever had.
And to be real I was like cuz it's about
me not you.
I will win.
I don't care if they're a mediocre
teacher. I'll still learn it. And I'll
still out-execute them and I'll get
better than they are at their own thing
so that people start asking me to teach
them.
And that's more or less happened
in my life.
But the idea that you can have like
there's no there's no savior. Jim Rohn
is not your savior.
We're not going to save anybody.
We'll tell you the stuff that you need
to do, and if you actually do it, you'll
win.
But the if you actually do it is the
part that most people suck at.
And so I'm trying to give you these
hours things of like, okay, buy buy 96
hours back.
I'm trying to give you this this stuff
of don't go into anything with the idea
that you want like if you ever buy
something with the intention of proving
that it doesn't work,
shame on you.
It sucks. What a terrible way to live.
Like go into it trying to be the person
who gets so good that they that the the
business
asks you for advice.
And I don't know where where when
something snaps in you, but like I've
seen it happen.
But there was a gym owner years ago who
was a Susan,
just moaned.
Just moaned. It's all I I'm moaning.
Just moaning all day about his life. And
I remember having like hopping on a call
or being a little bit rougher than I
normally am, and he like snapped out of
it.
And then he became one of the top gyms,
and then we hired him on.
Same guy.
Same information.
Completely different perspective on how
he chose to execute it.
And so like if you like so many here who
here got into fitness cuz you like
fitness? It was a passion of yours.
Right, you need to start learning how to
love business.
Cuz if you treated your business the way
you treated your body, you make a [__]
load more money.
And so one of the interesting things
about the fitness space is that I see
the posts. I actually see a lot more of
your guys' stuff than you guys think.
Where you make these posts about being
disciplined,
right? About doing the hard work when no
one's looking, right? It's right. Day
72, you know, still cranking. Still out
here 4:00 a.m. Getting it in.
But it doesn't make you tough because
you like it.
What makes you tough is doing [__] you
don't like.
And right now you don't work your leads.
You don't follow up with customers. You
don't send handwritten cards. You don't
have member events. You don't spend
money on ads. You don't learn editing
software so you can make better ads. You
don't research what you're going to say
in the ads so that they're actually
good. You don't practice your sales
scripts. You don't set up your lobby.
You don't put reviews online. You don't
ask people for reviews. You don't ask
people for referrals. You don't try to
make affiliate partners.
But you're tough.
Cuz you can drink egg whites.
The only person you fool is you.
And so I just I just
I want everyone here to make a lot of
money.
And I want you guys to have the gyms you
want.
And believe it or not, the gym business
has not changed.
You still have to promote it.
You still have to convert those leads.
And then when they come in, you have to
price appropriately so that when you're
at capacity you're making a lot of
money.
And you have to do whatever you can to
keep people.
That's not going to change.
It's just your dedication to the
execution of it that will.
And so I'll I'll bring up a my
my second to last point depending on
when they kick me off.
Your
team
sucks.
We thought earlier about your favorite
employee, right?
Now picture your least favorite
employee.
Also Susan.
Susan sucks.
So Susan, everybody got Susan in their
mind that that one person that you're
like You know it's our second quarter in
a row we've been I think she's going to
turn the corner. Yeah, I mean she's
she's kicking me tough sometimes. Yeah.
Fire Susan. Please. Fire Susan. She's
not going to turn around.
She's not going to make your business
better.
What you see is her best behavior.
Her best behavior.
And the moment you fire her, you're
going to hear horror stories from all
the customers that are going to come up
to you like, "Oh my god, thank god you
fired Susan. She was sleeping here once.
Oh my gosh, the other day you wouldn't
believe what she said to me." All of
this stuff.
Fire Susan. Because the other thing that
Susan does is she sets the bar
for your standards.
And I can tell you that the one of the
biggest things that like if I can
identify something in an entrepreneur to
know that they're going to win, I just
look at their team.
I don't even have to look at them. I
just because they're the ones doing it.
And I'll tell you a story.
Let's see if I can say I can tell a PG
version of this.
I'm just going to be real with you.
So
when I started talking to private equity
groups to consider selling a portion of
Gymshark so we could reinvest in some of
the stuff that you guys will see soon.
It's so
um
I had all these calls with investment
bankers and private equity groups.
And I remember so starkly the contrast
between the quality of the questions
that they were asking
and how intelligent every single person
on their team was
compared to my team
that I had built.
And we built you know, 50 to 100 million
dollar business.
Not bad.
But they were going to go make an extra
3 billion.
And it was this moment where I was like,
oh, there's just more levels. It just
keeps going.
Steve Jobs spent the vast majority of
his time bringing in talent.
Because fundamentally someone else can
run your facility better than you.
The problem is that you can't get that
person to work for you.
Because of who you are, because of the
people that you allow to be in your
vicinity.
They would walk in, they would see the
other people and be like, oh, I don't
want to associate with them.
And they just walk out the other side.
And so
you need to raise your standards.
And right now, I'll bet that the vast
majority of the people that work in your
business are mediocre.
And that's why your gym's mediocre.
Cuz if we're being real, they're the
ones that are doing everything.
They're the ones that are teaching the
classes, they're the ones not working
the leads when you tell them to, they're
the ones not following the sales script
when the person walks in the door,
they're the one forgetting to write the
handwritten cards, they're the ones that
show up late to the event that they're
supposed to be the champions of and
invite their people to, but they didn't.
They're the ones that don't wear the
uniform the way you asked them to
because they want to be special.
Has anyone dealt with any of this stuff?
Yes.
But you tolerate it.
And so it's your fault.
And so
the better, the higher my standards have
become, the better my teams have become,
the easier business has gotten, because
solving the business problems
aren't complicated. It's the everything
else.
It's the fact that Susan still takes up
your time.
The fact that you like, when you're in
bed at night and you're talking to your
spouse and you're like, "God, Susan, I
just I
I want to believe her, but this is the
third time she was late and I'm just
third time third
What happened after the first one?
Right?
And we're spending all this time, all
this bandwidth that you could be
spending actually improving the
business.
Not.
And so Susan's cost isn't just the fact
that she sucks at her job.
She also repels anyone who's good.
She also is bad with customers. And she
drains the single most important
resource from the most valuable employee
in the business, which is you.
And so you just have to raise the
standards. Like if I was going to spend
a day with each of you, I can promise
you
half the conversation I'd be like,
"Okay, so when you leave here today
you're going to you're going to stop
spending 96 hours a month on stuff that
you can outsource for $1,500.
You're going to spend the 4 hours you
just gained back actually doing whatever
the constraint of the business is so you
actually make more money.
And you're going to get rid of all the
people who suck. Now, part of you, I can
hear it here it. They're like, "But what
am I going to do with the bad work that
she's going to stop doing?"
Right?
What am I going to do about the work
she's not doing that she pretends to do
that I pay her for anyways?
And this is the real talk.
I'm burning through these pages.
I would say you can say it with me, but
we're going to miss time it and it'll be
really messy, so
so you can just think it with me.
Double time.
So this is a concept that
I have spent almost my entire life
living by.
Which is that I spend
half my day
working tomorrow's job.
And the other half of the day working my
day job.
And by thinking about my time this way,
I can move on double time. I can move at
twice the speed.
But that does compound over time. And so
if you have to take Susan's work over,
I'll bet you that what took Susan 20
hours that you pay her 40 for,
you can do in five.
And because you haven't done it in a
while, you probably realize there's a
bunch of systems you probably clean up.
And then, you'll get closer to the
customers, not a bad thing.
And when you bring that next person in,
you'll have been fresh on it and you can
actually train them how to do it the
right way.
And put a good feedback loop in for when
they do it right. So, one of the big
problems with management overall
is that it's basically, if I don't say
anything, you're doing great, and when
you mess up, I hammer you.
What you want to be able to do is give
people a cookie when a plane lands on
time,
rather than only when plane crashes
happen.
Because it's it's kind of like if you do
something for your spouse, let's say you
wash the dishes cuz they like that you
wash the dishes. If you do that three,
four, five times and they never say
thanks, you're just like, either this
isn't important or I just don't I don't
need to do this.
And they think the same way about their
role. So, if you just say, "Hey, do this
thing." and you never say it again and
you never tell them good job when they
do it, they will do it one time
and then stop doing it cuz you didn't
talk about it. And then you find out
months later that this thing you thought
was happening isn't happening and you've
been paying them for it the whole time.
And so, I promise you, if you think
Susan sucks, she probably sucks more
than you think she does. And she's not
doing nearly as much work as you think
she is, either. And the work she is
doing also probably not that good.
So, we have our big sticky note.
Number one,
4 hours
per day
on the constraint.
Which were What it sounds like everybody
here is you're not advertising enough.
Number two,
you're going to replace
all of the time that you spend doing
human stuff, you're going to pay someone
else to do it for you.
So, I'm going to say replace hours with
vendors
for human
stuff.
Three,
get rid
of Susan.
But, here's the thing.
I say this, we laugh, we have a good
time, you get on the plane, you go back,
and guess what you don't do?
You don't get rid of Susan.
So, let's let's let's explore this.
You don't get rid of Susan
because
you're afraid
of the conversation. And not the way you
think it is. Not like you're afraid of
Susan. I'm not afraid of Susan. Yeah, I
know. I know you're not afraid of Susan.
To some degree you like Susan.
Susan was there in the beginning.
You know, she she hasn't been
always the best, but she's been there
for you, you know?
And
you care about her as a human being. And
you're like, I don't know what Susan's
going to be able to do. I don't even
know if she'll be able to get a job
after this. Imagine, no one wants to
hire Susan. And that's what you're
afraid of.
You're like, so I'll do it.
And so, you then
decide, you know, I'm just going to have
a talking to her with her. That's what
I'm going to do. I'm not going to fire I
I know Alex said this, but
I know better.
So, I'm going to just going to tell her
she's missing expectation and it's not
her fault. It's not your fault, Susan. I
like I haven't I haven't been a good
communicator.
And I haven't been clear about it. And
and it's it's okay. This is a This is
good. This is communication. This is how
we get better, right? You have this
whole talk.
And Susan keeps sucking.
We laugh.
But this is what's going to happen for
90% of you in the room. You're not going
to do it.
And so the reason the vast majority of
business owners stay mediocre, stay
small, is because they can't make the
hard call.
They can't say, "I
love you, Susan.
I also love every other person who works
in this business and all of the
customers. And so I have to let you go."
And I still love you as a human being.
And then you're like, "Wow, that felt
great. Geez."
And then you look and you're like, "Oh
my god, she did this all wrong." Uh
And then you have space to go bring
someone else in who's right.
Because the process of building the gym
is that you learn all the roles, you do
them well, you train someone else to do
them, and then eventually, if you get
all those people right, you don't have
to do anything. And you can own the
asset. And then you can do it again.
As a side note, I haven't seen anybody
scale brick-and-mortar chain service
businesses without having an operator
that has a profit share.
I'm just letting you guys know. This is
what I've seen. It's usually 10 to 20%
They usually make somewhere in the
neighborhood of like 75 to 100,000 a
year.
So if right now you're like,
"I would really like this thing to just
be an asset that makes me money." Until
you can get to that point, it's not in
the cards.
Cuz somebody who really can run the
business is going to make seven, you
know, 75 grand to 100 grand
today
to do it.
And so you need to get everything so
dialed that they can make that and you
make money.
That's how it has to work. So I'm just
telling you guys right now, cuz the
amount of you, seen this one too,
my gym's making money.
I just signed a lease to my second
location even though I was literally not
profitable 4 months before gym launch.
Santana's seen it. You seen it a lot of
times. A lot of times.
Don't be that gym owner.
Get it so that you were bored out of
your mind
for months on end and you keep hitting
KPI, you keep growing, you keep becoming
more profitable. If you can't leave the
business for 6 months and it still grow,
you are not ready, the business model
isn't ready. Now, some of you are like,
"Man, that's a really high bar." Welcome
to growing a legitimate business.
So, what it is.
So,
we have 5 minutes left.
I want to make sure that the sticky note
that you actually do when you get home
has the right stuff on it.
Okay.
So,
who here after hearing this is like,
"I'm not advertising enough."
Thank you.
Who here is going to get rid of all the
human stuff for $1,500 a month so they
can do that?
Thank you.
And who here for the love of God
instead of wussing out and pretending
like you're making progress and saying
that you didn't communicate when you
really know that Susan's never going to
make it.
And maybe you just have to say, "I'm not
good enough of a manager."
You just have to say, "I'm not good
enough of a manager. You're amazing. I
suck. Either way, it's not working cuz I
can't fire me. I still got to be here."
Sorry.
Full credit, that's a Leila the
For the love of God, get rid of Susan.
And I'll give you a belief that I have
about about talent. Which is that you
absolutely can train anyone to do
anything. I believe that in my core.
The question is whether it's worth it.
Like I think everybody here could be a
neurosurgeon if given enough time.
It's just that who's going to pay for
that?
And some of you would take a while.
Like a while.
I've seen some of your hands, man. Some
[__] sausage like I don't know,
brain?
You could do it eventually.
But the question is whether you want to
be the one to incur the cost.
Because fundamentally all business is is
reallocation of resources. You have
time, you've got money, and you've got
energy. And you put it in, and the
people who get the best returns on it
make the most money.
And so when you're spending all this
time on Susan, you could just take a
seven and make them a 10.
And it would take you less time. You
literally get a better employee to be
better even faster
instead of riding this ride you keep
having with Susan over and over again.
Does everyone know who their Susan is in
their mind right now?
So, number three on the sticky note.
Will you please for the love of God get
rid of Susan?
Actually,
going to get hands?
All right. Please remember if you raised
your hand,
and 30 days from now Susan's still here,
I just need you to write
on your mirror,
and just accept the fact that you can't
have hard conversations, and you will
never grow your business.
You're in a service business. Service
businesses are people. It's culture
and training. All of those are
interacting with others.
If you cannot have a hard conversation,
which I define a hard conversation as
something It's easy to have a hard
conversation with someone you hate.
Cuz you're like, I've been waiting for
this.
I hate this guy.
Yeah, Todd, you know when you were
taking all those pictures of you
shirtless in the bathroom? Yeah,
customers didn't like it.
But I've been such a good Yeah, I got to
go. Sorry, man. Totally believe you,
think you're amazing. Be awesome. And
you're like, I hope that guy never calls
me again.
Easy if you hate the guy.
Hard if you like the person.
But like this is what being a grown-up
is. It's like you got to be able to have
these hard conversations. You got to be
able to say,
it's not working out.
And so many of you have personal issues.
I know this cuz I spent days and days
and days and days with deep dives in the
business. And gone honestly, you don't
need a deep dive in the business.
What you're not doing is obvious.
And so I put all my effort on why you're
not doing it.
Which is that your time is getting
sucked up with human stuff.
And your attention's getting drained by
girls like Susan and guys like Todd.
Cool?
All right. Thank you guys so much.